somewhere sophisticated stuff I see in
our man pads which is basically remote
guided missiles I've seen some of those
found out what is the application
exactly
a display of power there are no fly
zones over parts of Mexico
for this reason the new generation
cartel took down a helicopter
there's been incidents of military
helicopters falling from the sky and it
bit they've said that it was mechanical
issues
but that again I'm not I'm not uh gonna
do conspiracy theories out there uh but
there's there's a lot of videos on Tick
Tock of uh Cena Laura cartel forces at
parties you know carrying around uh
rocket launchers on their backs and you
know and so so there's an increased
probability of mechanical failures over
those areas when you're flying a
helicopter yeah there's no fly zones
over certain parts of Mexico okay and uh
um another thing you're seeing now is
night vision uh night vision equipment
uh that is clearly military grade from
the US that was probably abandoned in
some more field out there so maybe
Afghanistan or somewhere like that and
it's uh it's being found in safe houses
and in the hands of cartel forces you
want to talk about a scary opponent
somebody wearing night vision
with a suppressed firearm those types of
capabilities are now out there